[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen guten abend ihnen
allen katja eintracht frankfurt ist
frischgebackener europapokalsieger die
fans sind im rausch und wollen im team
einen wahnsinns empfangbarer genau die
sind auf dem weg zum römer dort werden
sie empfangen der regen ist
offensichtlich noch nicht angekommen
aber ich glaube dass heute auch egal ja
ja ja das und mehr findet sich jetzt
auch in unserem themen überblick
schlagabtausch im bundestag kanzler
scholz verspricht der ukraine weitere
hilfen der opposition reicht das nicht
grundsatzurteil zu corona das
bundesverfassungsgericht sagt ja zur
impfpflicht für das personal in
krankenhäusern und pflegeheimen
und ein fußball märchen wird wahr nach
dem europapokal sieg in sevilla feiert
und umjubelt frankfurt seine eintracht
helden
[Musik]
krieg zeitenwende waffenlieferungen
kanzler scholz erkläre seine politik nur
unzureichend so lautet die kritik zögern
und zaudern wirft ihm zuletzt
oppositionsführer märz im bundestag
entgegen ob olaf scholz in der heutigen
regierungserklärung sein handeln
deutlicher adressieren konnte und wie
der cdu schafft dieses mal darauf
reagiert dazu thomas reich hat
angekündigt ist eine regierungserklärung
es wird ein duell zwischen dem kanzler
und dem oppositionsführer zwischen stolz
und märz knapp drei monate her seiner
rede zur zeitenwende bekräftigt scholz
die ukraine mit waffen gegen russland zu
unterstützen
russland darf diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen die ukraine muss bestehen ich
will daher eines ganz deutlich sagen
einen brutal angegriffen land bei der
verteidigung zu helfen
darin liegt keine eskalation der kanzler
widerspricht auch allen die für einen
schnellen waffenstillstand fordern putin
entgegenzukommen einen diktat frieden
wird es nicht geben weil die ukraine
ukraine ihnen nicht akzeptieren und wir
auch nicht deshalb stärken wir die
ukraine den rücken auch militärisch wir
tun das überlebt abgewogen und
international eng abgestimmt friedrich
merz hingegen glaubt dass die regierung
bei den angekündigten waffenlieferungen
weniger abstimme sondern diese vielmehr
verschleppe die wahrheit ist doch dass
aus deutschland in den letzten wochen so
gut wie nichts an waffen geliefert
worden ist was machen sie denn was
treiben sie denn da für ein spiel auch
mit der deutschen öffentlichkeit märz
sich die verantwortung dafür
insbesondere bei der
verteidigungsministerin die stand
zuletzt wegen des umstrittenen mit flux
ihres sohnes in einem
bundeswehr-hubschrauber in der kritik
deswegen gebe ich ihnen den rat trennen
sie sich von dieser ministerin so
schnell wie möglich sie werden es
sowieso überall in den nächsten wochen
und monaten machen müssen die hft
behauptet der krieg gegen die ukraine
sei nicht deutschlands krieg auch die
linke lehnt waffenlieferungen nach wie
vor ab
dass man russland die größte atommacht
der welt mit militärischen mitteln in
die knie zwingen kann der irrt einfach
im gegenteil das ist ein
hochgefährlicher kurs scholz verspricht
der ukraine milliarden für den
wiederaufbau ist dabei gegen eine
schnelle eu-mitgliedschaft zu den star
gibt es keinen widerspruch von merz
wir bleiben bei der ukraine und finanzen
die ukraine braucht geld um den start am
laufen zu halten nach eigenen angaben
fehlen dem land monatlich rund fünf
milliarden euro beim treffen der
finanzminister der sieben größten
industrieländer in königswinter kündigte
bundesfinanzminister lindner an
kurzfristig mit einer milliarde euro zu
helfen auch andere länder der g7 runde
hätten zahlungen in aussicht gestellt um
sehr viel geld für die ukraine geht es
auch in washington um ein
milliardenschweres hilfspaket vor
wenigen minuten hat dem jetzt auch der
us senat zugestimmt wir wollen
nachfragen bei elmar theveßen in
washington elmar ukraine hilfen von 40
milliarden us-dollar sind auf den weg
gebracht eine unglaubliche summe ist es
welche bedeutung welchen stellenwert hat
dieser umfang
ja das hat höchste bedeutung so etwas
passiert eigentlich selten bis nie hier
in washington der präsident hatte um 33
milliarden dollar gebeten nun bekommt er
40 milliarden dollar vom kongress zur
verfügung gestellt etwa die hälfte geht
in waffenhilfe an die ukraine 1 voran in
patriot flugabwehrsysteme aber auch in
artilleriegeschütze mit großer
reichweite 8 milliarden wirtschaftshilfe
für die ukraine dann auch mehrere
milliarden fünf milliarden insgesamt um
die nahrungsmittel engpässe die folge
des ukraine krieges sind in der welt zu
bekämpfen und eine milliarde mit den
flüchtlingen den flüchtlingen zu helfen
dass insgesamt von einer großen mehrheit
im senat ist ein signal man sagt hier
für den langen atem man will zeigen dass
man dauerhaft an der seite der ukraine
steht und dass auch lange über diesen
krieg hinaus damit eben dieser einsatz
der auch heute wieder in der abstimmung
deutlich wurde sich langfristig für die
usa für den westen für die
wertegemeinschaft gelohnt hat dankeschön
motive sind nach washington gerade hast
du von langem atem gesprochen das passt
zur nächsten meldung was militärexperte
nämlich schon länger prognostizieren
machte ukraine ist präsident heute auch
deutlich sie lenski bereitet sein volk
auf einen längeren krieg vor und plante
das und plant das verhängte kriegsrecht
um drei weitere monate zu verlängern
weiter tobt die deutung schlacht um die
soldaten aus dem stahlwerk von mario
pohl dazu luden linus ihr widerstand ist
am ende zerschellt an der übermacht der
angreifer das ist die botschaft dieser
bilder entstanden sind sie im auftrag
der russischen regierung sie sollen
sagen die ukrainischen gefangenen werden
gut behandelt
die haftbedingungen sind mehr als
akzeptabel es gibt matratzen web laden
das essen muss daran gemessen es gibt
genug von allem
und aus einer klinik präsentiert die
russische propaganda ukrainische
gefangene mit solchen aussagen
ich werde gut behandelt niemand
misshandelt mich weder physisch noch
psychisch
umgekehrt versucht die regierung in kiew
die moral mit solchen aufnahmen
hochzuhalten ukrainische polizisten
verteilen hilfsgüter an die bevölkerung
im osten zugleich schwarze lenz geht die
menschen auf einen langen krieg an
wir sind verpflichtet die besetzer zu
vertreiben und echte sicherheit der
ukraine zu garantieren ich plädiere
dafür das kriegsrecht um 90 tage zu
verlängern im gleichen atemzug macht sie
längst geht den menschen in den
besetzten gebieten zwischen mario pohl
und persson hoffnung dass die ukraine
sie befreien wird darunter auch das akw
ist borussia in der stadt sa borussia
befürchten sie gerade das gegenteil sie
ist nur wenige kilometer entfernt und
noch ukrainisch kontrolliert praktisch
täglich erwarten sie hier den versuch
der russen die stadt einzunehmen
nachdem finnland und schweden jetzt
offiziell die nato aufnahme beantragt
haben die türkei als mitglied dies aber
bislang ablehnt laufen im hintergrund
die drähte heiss um ankara umzustimmen
die usa geben sich optimistisch
präsident biden empfing heute finnlands
präsidentin und schwedens regierungschef
in im weißen haus über die geplante nord
stärkung der nato und den widerstand
florian neumann
im garten des weißen hauses haben sie
sich einiges vorgenommen heute bilder
für die geschichtsbücher zu produzieren
mit gesten wie dieser besetzen wie jenen
wehrmann finnland und schweden machen
die nato stärker
heute bin ich stolz beiden ländern sagen
zu können sie haben die absolute voller
unterstützung der usa
der neue eintrag im geschichtsbuch aber
steht weiter unter vorbehalt aus der
türkei auch heute wiederholt der
türkische präsident seinen vorwurf die
beiden länder unterstützten kurdische
terrororganisationen
wir haben den verantwortlichen in der
nato gesagt dass wir nein zum beitritt
finnlands und schwedens sagen werden
daran werden wir auch festhalten
es ist ein vorwurf auf dem der finnische
präsident in washington direkt antwortet
terrorismus sehr ernst wir verurteilen
den terrorismus in all seinen formen und
wir beteiligen uns aktiv an seiner
bekämpfung
viele vermuten der türkei gehe es eher
um die lieferung von rüstungsgütern etwa
solcher kampfjets aus den usa vom
nato-generalsekretär dort zu heute bei
einem besuch in dänemark nur so viel
wenn ein wichtiger verbündeter wie die
türkei sicherheitsbedenken geäußert ist
der einzige weg sich gemeinsam
hinzusetzen
an der sitzung der nato militärchefs
nahmen die vertreter schwedens und
finnlands heute derweil schon mal teil
als partner noch nicht als mitglieder
was ich schon abzeichnete hat der
haushaltsausschuss des bundestages jetzt
beschlossen spd-altkanzler gerhard
schröder verliert sein staatlich
finanziertes büro samt mitarbeiter
stellen seit kriegsbeginn steht schröder
wegen seiner putin nähe und seiner
posten bei russischen energieunternehmen
verstärkt in der kritik das
europaparlament für schröder sogar auf
die sanktionsliste der eu setzen jetzt
nach schleswig-holstein da ist eine
neuauflage der jamaika-koalition vom
tisch und damit die wunsch koalition von
ministerpräsident daniel günther er
bedauere dies sehr sagte er nach einem
sondierungsgespräch günther wollte
weiter mit den grünen und der fdp fdp
reagieren obwohl er auch mit nur einer
der parteien eine hyde gehabt hätte
jetzt zu corona von anfang an war sie
stark umstritten jetzt die klarstellung
des bundesverfassungsgerichts ist die
impfpflicht in pflege und medizinischen
einrichtungen ist rechtens
sie gilt seit mitte märz für alle
beschäftigten in der pflege in
arztpraxen und kliniken ein blick auf
deutschlands zeigt dass es da durchaus
große unterschiede gibt bei der
impfbereitschaft in nordrhein westfalen
sind wie in vielen anderen bundesländern
knapp zehn prozent der beschäftigten
nicht geimpft in schleswig holstein sind
es nur etwa 3 und in sachsen mehr als 30
prozent birgit franke
sozialbetreuerin gabriele pauli arbeitet
seit 23 jahren im altenpflegeheim st
hedwig in wittenburg sie mag ihre arbeit
sehr gegen korona will sich aber nicht
impfen lassen sie hat angst vor dem
impfstoff die frage wie es für sie
weitergeht belastet sie
wird doch das bundesverfassungsgericht
hat die impfpflicht für pflegekräfte
ärzte und krankenhauspersonal bestätigt
impfungen seien wichtig um alte und vor
erkrankte zu schützen dagegen seien die
nachteile für die im pflichtigen
berufsgruppen gering der
bundesgesundheitsminister begrüßt die
entscheidung die umsetzung der in
richtungs bezogenen impfpflicht durch
die einrichtungen hat mit dazu
beigetragen dass nicht noch mehr
menschen in der mikrowelle mit der wir
derzeit ringen müssen gestorben sind der
pflegerat hingegen will mehr eine
allgemeine impfpflicht werden im herbst
in eine neue welle kommen wir wissen
dass dass es so ist und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir als gesellschaft diese
infektion verhindern es ist ungerecht es
auf das medizinische und pflegerische
personal abzuwälzen und so hoffen dass
wir das ding retten würden gabriele
pauli hat das erste schreiben vom
gesundheitsamt erhalten ohne impfung
droht ihr ein bußgeld bis zu 2500 euro
und später eventuell der jobverlust im
heim
der bundestag macht heute über stunden
in einer sitzung bis nach mitternacht
sollen zahlreiche gesetze verabschiedet
werden beschlossen wurde bereits die
weitreichende streichung von sanktionen
für hartz 4 empfänger nur bei
wiederholten melde verstößen können
leistungen gekürzt werden verlängert hat
das parlament die entlastungen wegen der
korona pandemie für viele arbeitnehmer
wichtig die home office pauschale bei
der steuer gilt auch für dieses jahr
heute haben viele noch mal sommerliches
wetter genießen können andere hingegen
bereiten sich auf gefährlich heftige
unwetter mit schwerpunkt in nordrhein
westfalen vor die dann weiterziehen und
morgen auch weiter toben sollen
starkregen hagel und tornado gefahr
nichts was man unterschätzen sollte wie
christoph distel erklärt
bad neuenahr-ahrweiler noch kein jahr
ist das katastrophale hoch was er hier
vor dem neuen regen gibt die stadt
morgens sandsäcke aus am bauhof maximal
zehn säcke pro abholer zwei lange
schlangen bilden sich alle sagen lieber
zu vorsichtig als noch einmal wehrlos
gegen wassermassen
weiter nördlich an der niederländischen
grenze kann man förmlich spüren wie sich
die atmosphäre am nachmittag aufheizt
auch in ahaus steigen die temperaturen
quasi minütlich schwere böen kommen auf
dann ein sandsturm im trockenen und
schließlich das gewitter es ist kein
normales frühlingswetter wir haben
derzeit sehr viel wärme ist es geradezu
heiß und dazu kommt morgen die
feuchtigkeit das ist eine explosive
mischung und durchaus ziemlich
ungewöhnlich für mai vom nordwesten haus
ziehen die unwetter ins land norden und
süden bleiben wohl einigermaßen
verschont für alle anderen regionen
warnen die meteorologen heute das gehe
gerade noch der kritische tag sei morgen
ein tief zieht auf und wird mit heftigen
gewittern einhergehen das sind
regelrechte unwetter mit starkregen
hagel und sturm teils orkanböen also das
ist eine richtig gefährliche lage in
krefeld hat er schon jetzt eine unwetter
zelle zerstörerische kraft
ein blitz zusammenbrechen dieses dach
auf die feuerwehr kommt rechtzeitig und
kann verhindern dass ein brand ausbricht
am abend dann beginnt es auch in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler wieder zuschütten
harmlos oder folgenschwer bei dieser
extreme wetterlage lässt sich das kaum
vorhersagen
es war ein historischer triumph der sieg
der frankfurter eintracht im finale der
fußball- europa-league gestern in
sevilla gegen die glasgow rangers nach
einer sehr kurzen nacht ist die
mannschaft schon wieder zurück in der
heimat um 17.40 landete die maschine aus
spanien auf dem frankfurter flughafen
kapitän sebastian rode und trainer
oliver glasner kam als erste mit dem
pokal aus dem flieger und inzwischen
befindet sich die mannschaft auf dem weg
zum frankfurter römer dort warten
tausende fans der eintracht seit stunden
um gemeinsam mit ihren helden feiern zu
können und für uns dort ist markus
wolsiffer es ist rappelvoll markus ist
da überhaupt noch platz für die eintrag
[Applaus]
ich denke auf dem balkon gibt es noch
ein kleines plätzchen hier unten wird es
aber eng 13.000 zuschauer sind
zugelassen mehr dürfen nicht rein
insgesamt erwartet die polizei etwa
100000 sie verteilen sich partitionen am
main ist natürlich auch beliebt wir
haben es gesehen die mannschaft ist
pünktlich gelandet das wurde hier auf
den video screen gezeigt da war der
jubel riesig es naht der höhepunkt der
pokal kommt zum römer erst will sich die
mannschaft noch in das goldene buch
eintragen und dann wird es bald soweit
sein der pokal auf den balkon der
kapitän will nach oben halten wir sind
sehr gespannt das war eine
eindrucksvolle leistung natürlich geht
der blick nach oben ist gewinner des
best wir sind gespannt was dabei
rauskommt vielen vielen dank markus was
für eine sause dort ja der größte erfolg
der vereinsgeschichte samt fan rausch
und party am römer dann auch thema
gleich um 19.30 bei den kollegen von
heute live und damit jetzt zu katja und
dem sportlichen teil dieses wahnsinns
erfolgt ja man braucht auch als
zuschauer sehr viel ausdauer und gute
nerven denn dieses finale ging wie es
sich für einen echten fußball final
krimi gehört ins elfmeterschießen und
der 65 endstand gegen die glasgow
rangers wurde dann der beginn einer
langen langen partynacht ein
[Musik]
kleiner teil der mitgereisten fans
bekommt in sevilla schon mal einen
siegesfeier vorgeschmack mit
gesangseinlage
raphael burri hat das elfmeterschießen
für eintracht frankfurt entschieden von
andalusien aus schwappt die
begeisterungswelle bis an den main wo
zigtausende den ersten deutschen europa
league sieger feiern und ihr glück kaum
fassen können wir hatten das dieses jahr
dann auch das quäntchen glück haben es
aber auch hervorragenden spielen gemacht
und ist unglaublich wir sind unglaublich
stolz im fokus von deutschland zu sein
es ist das erwartet schwere spiel auf
augenhöhe 57 minute diego bringt die
ranger sind führung die eintracht gleich
schnell aus 69 minute schon das macht
raphael poirée 11 verlängerung da
verhindert kevin trapp im eintrag tor
kurz vor schluss den rückstand bevor er
im elfmeterschießen den schuss von aaron
ramsey
abwehrt die vorentscheidung
[Applaus]
europacup-sieger die champions league
nächstes jahr in topf 1
den supercup ich weiß gar nicht um den
supercup geht es dann im august
tatsächlich gegen den
champions-league-sieger madrid oder
liverpool das team von oliver glasner
kann sich bis dahin feiern lassen für
den ersten internationalen vereins
triumph seit 42 jahren
derweil ist ein anderer bundesligist
nämlich der vfl wolfsburg fündig
geworden bei der suche nach einem neuen
trainer niko kovac ehemaliger trainer
beim fc bayern und auch bei eintracht
frankfurt übernimmt nach
übereinstimmenden medienberichten die
funktion mit sofortiger wirkung kovac
folgt auf florian coesfeld der am
sonntag überraschen überraschend
entlassen worden war kovac soll einen
dreijahres-vertrag erhalten ja noch zur
eishockey wm nach finnland dort sollte
heute am frühen nachmittag das deutsche
team eigentlich sein viertes vorrunden
spiel absolvieren gegen dänemark aber
eine halbe stunde vor spielbeginn wurde
die halle komplett geräumt ein kleiner
brand hatte ein feueralarm ausgelöst der
aber schnell gelöscht wurde die
deutschen spieler erwarteten in voller
ausrüstung und teilweise mit
schlittschuhen an den füßen dann vor der
halle das spiel wurde inzwischen aber
angepfiffen ist gerade eben zu ende
gegangen deutschland gewinnt 1 0 gegen
dänemark verrückt ja dankeschön galt ja
passen sie bitte in den unwetter
regionen auf sich auf weitere details
dazu gleich mehr christa thoben um 21
uhr 45 sei ihnen das heute journal
empfohlen mit christian sievers von uns
war es dass wir heute abend das gesamte
team der heute 19 wünsche ihnen noch
einen entspannten abend vielen dank und
gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend ja eine schwere gewitter lager hat
uns im griff aktuell zieht schon eine
linie mit gewittern über das land mit
diesem ersten kleinen tief morgen
erreicht uns dann aber das größte
unwetterpotenzial mit diesem zweiten
kleinen tief aber der reihe nach
zunächst einmal heute nacht da zieht die
linie mit den gewittern etwas richtung
osten sie reicht dann etwa von
nordbayern bis an die ostsee in der
zweiten nachthälfte fällt das ganze hier
etwas in sich zusammen dafür steigt die
unwettergefahr
im westen des landes wieder an und
morgen vormittag haben wir es mit diesen
gewittern dann auch über der mitte des
landes zu tun ansonsten aber erstmal
noch trocken und meist freundlich doch
mal nachmittags entwickeln sich dann
eben diese schweren unwetter artigen
gewitter und vor was warnen wir da jetzt
zum einen starkregen mit über 40
millimetern in der stunde das kann lokal
überflutungen auslösen dann vor hagel
bruch mit großem hagel und auch vor
orkanböen in diesem gewittern und auch
tornados sind nicht ausgeschlossen das
ganze beginnt nachmittags im westen des
landes und am abend geht es dann auch im
osten des landes rund passen sie also
auf sich auf wir schauen auch schnell
auf die temperaturen 10 bis 17 grad in
der nacht morgen tagsüber dann 18 bis 25
grad im norden im süden wieder heiß mit
bis 34 grad und am wochenende beruhigt
sich das wetter wieder